Imagínate si la mitad de la gente
de tu vecindario, tu ciudad,
o incluso de todo tu país
fuera eliminada.
Puede sonar como algo salido de
una película de terror apocalíptico,
pero fue lo que realmente
sucedió en el siglo XIV
durante un brote de la enfermedad
conocida como la Peste Negra
Difundida desde China a través de Asia,
Oriente Medio, África y Europa,
la epidemia devastadora destruyó tanto
como un quinto de la población mundial,
matando a casi el 50% de
los europeos en solo 4 años.
Una de las cosas más fascinantes
y desconcertantes de la Peste Negra
es que la enfermedad en sí
no era un fenómeno nuevo,
sino que había afectado a
los seres humanos durante siglos.
Análisis del ADN de muestras de hueso
y de los dientes de este período,
así como de una epidemia
anterior conocida
como la Peste de Justiniano
en 541 d.C.
han revelado que ambas
fueron causadas por la Yersinia pestis,
la misma bacteria que causa
la peste bubónica en la actualidad.
Lo que esto significa es
que la misma enfermedad
causada por el mismo patógeno
puede comportarse y
extenderse de manera
muy diferente a
lo largo de la historia.
Incluso antes del
uso de antibióticos,
los brotes mortíferos
en los tiempos modernos,
tales como los que se produjeron
a principios de siglo XX en la India,
mataron no más del
3 % de la población.
Casos modernos de plaga también
tienden a permanecer localizados,
o viajar lentamente, a medida que
se propagan por las pulgas de roedores.
Pero la Peste Negra medieval,
que se extendió como reguero de pólvora,
fue probablemente transmitida
directamente de una persona a otra.
Y dado que las comparaciones genéticas
de la antigua y la moderna cepa
de Yersinia pestis
no han revelado ninguna diferencia
funcional genética significativa,
la clave del porqué el brote
anterior fue mucho más letal
no debe estar en el parásito,
sino en el anfitrión.
Por cerca de 300 años,
durante la Alta Edad Media,
un clima más cálido
y mejoras agrícolas
habían llevado a un crecimiento explosivo
de la población en toda Europa.
Pero con tantas nuevas
bocas que alimentar,
el final del período de calentamiento
significó un desastre.
Las altas tasas de fertilidad combinadas
con la cosecha reducida,
significaron que el suelo ya no podía
sostener a su población,
mientras que la abundante oferta de mano
de obra mantenía bajos los salarios.
Como resultado, la mayoría de
los europeos en el siglo XIV
experimentaron una disminución
constante del nivel de vida,
marcada por el hambre,
la pobreza y la mala salud,
dejándolos vulnerables a la infección.
Y de hecho, los restos óseos de víctimas
de la Peste Negra encontrados en Londres
muestran signos reveladores de
desnutrición y enfermedades previas.
La destrucción causada
por la Peste Negra
cambió la humanidad en
dos aspectos importantes.
A nivel social,
la rápida pérdida de población
dio lugar a cambios importantes en
las condiciones económicas de Europa.
Con más comida para todos,
así como más tierras
y mejores salarios
para los agricultores y
trabajadores que sobrevivieron,
la gente empezó a comer
mejor y vivir más tiempo
como lo muestran los estudios
de los cementerios de Londres.
Niveles de vida más altos también trajeron
un aumento en la movilidad social,
debilitando el feudalismo, y finalmente,
conduciendo a reformas políticas.
Pero la plaga también tuvo
un impacto biológico importante.
La repentina muerte de muchas de
las personas más frágiles y vulnerables
dejó una población con una reserva
genética significativamente diferente,
incluidos los genes que
pudieron haber ayudado
a que los sobrevivientes
resistieran a la enfermedad.
Y debido a que tales mutaciones
confieren a menudo inmunidades
a múltiples patógenos
que actúan de manera similar,
la investigación para descubrir las
consecuencias genéticas de la Peste Negra
tiene el potencial de
ser muy beneficiosa.
Hoy en día, la amenaza de una epidemia
en la escala de la Peste Negra
se ha eliminado en gran medida
gracias a los antibióticos.
Pero la peste bubónica sigue
matando a unos cuantos miles
de personas en el mundo cada año
y la reciente aparición de una cepa
resistente a los medicamentos
amenaza el regreso de
los tiempos más oscuros.
Aprender más acerca de las causas
y efectos de la Peste Negra es importante,
no solo para la comprensión de cómo
nuestro mundo ha sido moldeado por el pasado.
También puede ayudar a salvarnos
de una pesadilla similar en el futuro.